grazie Allora c'è un esercizio che si
può fare divertente oggi che è quello di
chiedere ai manager delle grandi imprese
del mondo se la loro azienda è
sostenibile e loro immediatamente
assumeranno una posizione compiaciuta e
vi cominceranno a dire che sono
straordinariamente sostenibili per
esempio
se lo Chiedete a un manager di una
grande compagnia assicurativa vi
comincerà a dire quanto hanno smesso di
stampare su carta i contratti per i loro
clienti così salvano gli alberi che
hanno sostituito le bottigliette di
plastica con i dispenser che hanno
rivestito gli uffici con dei pannelli
fotovoltaici che hanno smesso di
investire in operazioni finanziarie che
creano danni al Pianeta tutte cose
importantissime però a un certo punto
dovete fargli la la domanda chiave e la
domanda chiave è sì ma tu
l'assicurazione vita ai diabetici
cronici la offri o non la offri e
siccome la risposta Sarà No qui abbiamo
un problema e il problema è che noi
veniamo da una stagione di sostenibilità
facile di sostenibilità in cui si sono
scelti Fior da Fiore gli obiettivi che
si potevano perseguire senza mettere
tanto in discussione il profitto oggi
inizia un'altra fase una fase di
scarsità di risorse e di vincoli
abbondanti in cui Invece noi dobbiamo
perseguire obiettivi che mettono a
rischio il modo di fare profitto che
abbiamo avuto fino a ieri e questo è un
enorme problema e quando il manager vi
risponde no io la assicurazione ai
diabetici cronici non la offro la offro
a condizioni molto particolari quello
che vi dovete chiedere è ma sta
proteggendo il profitto della sua
impresa o sta semplicemente dichiarando
la sua incapacità di innovare perché se
lui avesse voglia di innovare di
esplorare quello che l'innovazione gli
mette a disposizione i cosiddetti
wearable Devices quegli aggeggi che
tengono sotto controllo i livelli del
sangue le nuove terapie gli
accompagnamenti che si possono fare ai
diabetici cronici si accorgerebbe che
quel pezzo di mercato chiamiamolo pure
col suo nome che quei soggetti che hanno
bisogno non solo di essere oggetto di
mercato ma anche di protezione di cui
sono sprovvisti sono dei soggetti che
sono perfettamente compatibili con i
suoi obiettivi di perseguimento di
profitto e di creazione di valore per
gli azionisti quindi il non essere
sostenibili radicalmente significa
semplicemente non essere capaci di
innovare e l'innovazione è quella cosa
che riesce a far stare insieme
l'aggiunta di un'unità di impatto
sociale positivo a l'unità di profitto
Allora Questa potrebbe essere una buona
notizia Abbiamo la soluzione per fare
della sostenibilità radicale
trasformativa che realmente cambia il
mondo cosa che non abbiamo fatto in
questi passati 20 anni la cosa che
dobbiamo fare è essere innovativi perché
innovazione e sostenibilità sono
sinonimi C'è però un problema che
L'innovazione che abbiamo praticato in
questi anni Beh in questi 50 anni almeno
è un'innovazione che ha dei problemi ha
un problema fondamentale che è stata
concepita in un mondo di R abbondanti e
di vincoli scarsi e quindi noi ci
potevamo permettere un'innovazione super
performante aggressiva muscolare che non
teneva conto del fatto che si stavano
usando intensivamente le risorse del
pianeta e soprattutto che si continuava
ad accumulare un serbatoio di
diseguaglianze e di esclusione che a un
certo punto arriva a un pezzo di
tensione e quali problemi ha questa
innovazione che noi abbiamo forgiato in
un mondo di Abbondanza ha
sostanzialmente due problemi Il primo è
che viene con tanta innovazione inutile
Il secondo è che ha spesso delle
conseguenze in attese Che cos'è
l'innovazione inutile l'innovazione
inutile è quell' innovazione che arriva
a risolvere dei problemi dove la guida
al mercato probabilmente non
fondamentali non è L'innovazione che
vedete dei contadini sul lago inra i
conteni sul lago Ina erano stufi di
avere due volte all'anno le coltivazioni
distrutte dai monsoni
e hanno cominciato hanno deciso di
cominciare a coltivare la loro frutta e
la loro verdura su delle piattaforme
galleggianti fatte di fieno e fango
un'innovazione straordinaria di valori
di mercato praticamente Nullo dall'altra
parte se facciamo un'analogia di
innovazioni galleggianti il casinò
galleggiante forse non l'innovazione più
utile al mondo ma un'innovazione
popolarissima dal punto di vista del
mercato e questo è il sistema di
incentivi che ha definito quell'essere
in un mondo m sostanzialmente di
abbondanza Cioè quel mondo che ha
performato creando migliaia di app per
il pizza Delivery dove il punto
fondamentale Domino da solo ne ha 17 Il
punto fondamentale era riuscire a fare
una app di pizza Delivery che
consentisse di ordinare una pizza in
meno di 17 secondi sapete perché meno di
17 secondi Sapete qual è il bisogno
riuscire a ordinare una pizza mentre si
ha al semaforo perché 17 secondi è più o
meno il tempo che abbiamo Durante Il
Semaforo rosso Ecco tutta questa
innovazione inutile è un'innovazione che
ci potevamo permettere come
sottoprodotto dell'Innovazione utile in
un mondo abbondante Probabilmente oggi
quelle risorse che vanno a quei pezzi di
innovazione Dovremmo cercare di
utilizzarli in maniera diversa però c'è
anche il secondo problema Il secondo
problema è il problema legato
a questa frase che è una frase un po'
dura Chi ha inventato la barca ha
inventato il naufragio che significa
semplicemente l'innovazione viene sempre
con delle conseguenze inattese Non è
neanche lontanamente una cosa per
demonizzare l'innovazione l'innovazione
va celebrata ma celebrarla significa
anche guardare a quelle cose a quei
prodotti in attesi che si generano e
hanno dei costi sociali e ambientali
molto molto importanti La prima ovvia
che ci viene sempre in mente è quella
legata al lavoro alla disoccupazione
indotta dall'innovazione tecnologica in
questo caso il racconto di Steinbeck dei
cittadini dei contadini nelle Grandi
Pianure americane che con la
meccanizzazione dell'Agricoltura con dei
costi sociali enormi devono migrare
verso la California o le tessitrici
dell'Inghilterra della fine del X secolo
rimpiazzate dalla meccanizzazione
dell'Industria Tessile Questa è il costo
più semplice che ci viene sempre in
mente anche se abbiamo dimostrato gli
economisti hanno dimostrato che alla
fine poi le cose si mettono a posto
l'innovazione tanto distrugge quanto
crea Bene benissimo Però nel transitorio
c'è della gente che se la passa
malissimo e di questa gente forse non
possiamo più
disinteressarsi scorsi 30 anni noi
Abbiamo affidato a questa metafora
questa retorica dell'economia della
conoscenza grandi speranze di prosperità
l'idea qual era l'idea era che c'erano
gli startupper c'era l'alta tecnologia
c'erano i brevetti c'erano gli
intangibili software e tutta questa roba
qua senza neanche discussione si diceva
Guardate che questa cosa creerà talmente
tanta prosperità che non dobbiamo
neanche preoccuparci della
ridistribuzione di questa ricchezza
perché questa zampilla Naturalmente in
modo equo e giusto su tutte le persone
non è successo così per esempio grandi
economisti ci dimostrano che in Europa
Nell'era dell'economia della conoscenza
le diseguaglianze territoriali sono
aumentate esponenzialmente cioè molti
pezzi di territorio molte comunità non
esistono più sono semplicemente rimasta
indietro Questo è un sottoprodotto di
quell'idea di innovazione mascolina e
aggressiva però dobbiamo anche guardare
quei modelli di innovazione che abbiamo
tanto celebrato perché venivano
dall'idea del sharing che era un ottima
idea dal punto di vista dell'Innovazione
sociale e allora per esempio se voi
pensate il Car Sharing Car to Go sono
tutte cose che noi abbiamo celebrato per
l'appunto perché si producono meno
macchine perché c'è meno traffico meno
inquinamento tutte cose bellissime Un
pochino influenzate dalla nostra idea
dal nostro condizionamento mentale che
la sostenibilità è soprattutto una
questione verde e molto meno una
questione sociale Tant'è vero che quando
abbiamo progettato il Car shelling e
abbiamo detto che era un'idea
meravigliosa a nessuno è venuto in mente
che tutti abbiamo un amico in sedi a
rotelle e che quell'amico in sedia a
rotelle il Car shelling non lo può usare
non era una cosa difficile pensarci
abbiamo mandato l'uomo sulla Luna e
quindi forse le macchine con
un'accessibilità per il nostro amico
insediare hotelle forse potevamo
immaginar Cele E se qualcuno se a
qualcuno in questo momento è venuto in
mente Sì vabbè ma non è che che
l'innovazione può servire proprio tutti
sono d'accordo l'innovazione non può
servire Proprio tutti ma non sempre gli
stessi soprattutto non può escludere
sempre gli stessi e la stessa questione
vale per esempio per il Food sharing il
Food sharing era una cosa straordinaria
eliminiamo lo spreco di cibo chi
potrebbe essere contrario a quest'idea
Eh certo Però ci sono i
Rider Qualcuno ha immaginato quando
Airbnb ha cominciato a fare cose
bellissime cioè
dematerializzare l'industria
dell'ospitalità
consentire ai giovani di viaggiare cose
bellissime Però con questo sono
venuti gli affitti brevi che
determinavano un inaccessibilità
sostanziale nelle grandi città europee
da cui non per caso Airbnb è stata
espulsa e dei fenomeni di
gentrificazione che lasciavano la
signora che abita in un centro storico
di un villaggio italiano in una
condizioni di assoluta deprivazione
sociale Questi
pezzi di negatività che promanano
dall'innovazione non sono una
conseguenza scontata Non tutto si può
può prevedere Ma alcune cose dobbiamo
cominciar le a prevedere e dobbiamo
anche ricordarci che l'innovazione è un
grande servitore dell'efficienza e noi
riconosciamo l'abbiamo concepito
l'efficienza come il grande principio
ordinatore delle nostre attività
economiche allora il punto Qual è il
punto è
che ammettete che una impresa una
società che distribuisce pasti negli
ospedali venga dal Politecnico a
chiedere un algoritmo di intelligenza
artificiale come fanno tutti in questo
periodo che consenta di prevedere
esattamente il numero di ricoverati
nell'ospedale due giorni dopo in modo in
cui in modo che l'impresa possa non
sprecare neanche un pasto possa portare
in ospedale esattamente il numero di
pasti necessario e a tutti noi sembra
una cosa bellissima perché il
Politecnico che è una grande università
fa questo algoritmo che prevede
esattamente il numero di pazienti che
saranno in ospedale e da oggi nessun
pasto sarà più sprecato con tutte le sue
conseguenze positive quello che accadrà
però il giorno in cui inizierà questa
storia è che verrà un signore un po'
dimesso e ci dirà siete voi il
Politecnico che avete fatto questo
meraviglioso algoritmo e noi diremo di
sì e lui dirà Invece io sono il
Presidente dell'Associazione che usava i
pasti avanzati Per sfamare i poveri e
gli Homeless in via Vittor Pisani come
facciamo stasera e questo è un problema
serio perché per stasera non abbiamo una
soluzione il punto Qual è il punto è che
l'inefficienza ha delle proprietà
prosociali e bisogna stare attenti a
smontarle bisogna progettare il
transitorio da inefficienza a efficienza
in modo che non siano sempre gli stessi
a pagare i costi sociali della
transizione verso l'efficienza questa
sarà un'altra delle proprietà che
andranno pensate per l'innovazione e a
me ha molto
colpito recentemente sentire la
presentazione di una società che ha
ricevuto dei finanziamenti
importantissimi che fa intelligenza
artificiale e quando voi vi confrontate
con società che fanno intelligenza
artificiale vi confrontate con dei
soggetti che tipicamente usano quantità
di risorse enormi e che hanno la super
prestazione della rete neurale che
Abilita il machine Learning con cui gira
l'algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale
bene questi signori Si sono presentati
su un palco e hanno detto Guardate che
non sta più in piedi l'intelligenza
artificiale basata su un uso enorme di
capacità di calcolo e di energia noi
dobbiamo
fare intelligenza artificiale frugale si
chiama
Focus intelligenza artificiale frugale è
una cosa che mi ha molto colpito per
perché noi l'innovazione frugale la
conosciamo da tantissimo tempo
nell'emisfero sud del mondo si vive di
innovazione frugale l'emisfero Sud del
mondo è cap Noi abbiamo le le caraffe
che purificano l'acqua già pura sulle
nostre tavole l'innovazione frugale è
quell'oggetto da cui si beve nel fango
per capirci cioè delle innovazioni che
ci consentono di fare con le risorse che
abbiamo delle cose molto molto
importanti Eccola La grande novità
l'innovazione frugale che guarda caso è
cresciuta e prosper in luoghi in cui le
risorse erano scarse i vincoli
strettissimi comincia a attraversare il
mondo dell'alta tecnologia e i paesi
industrializzati e questa è la grande
questione che abbiamo di fronte il nuovo
modello il nuovo paradigma di
innovazione Ra affonda le sue radici
nella frugalità e dove la impariamo la
frugalità applicata all'alta tecnologia
che guardate non è fare le cose con poco
rinunciare decrescere non è questo è
essere frugali nell'utilizzo delle
risorse che abbiamo quelle del pianeta e
quelle sociali dove impariamo e
chiudiamo con l'ultima storiella c'è una
storiella che è quella Se voi girate per
le zone rurali dell'Asia Sud pacifica
ogni tanto vedete delle case in cui le
persone invece di avere delle finestre
fanno delle specie di tavoli
ricompensato in cui piantano delle
bottiglie di plastica col fondo tagliato
perché fanno questo per il principio di
Venturi che dubito che conoscano però
l'aria entra nella parte più larga della
bottiglia si comprime nel collo della
bottiglia accelera e produce una sorta
di effetto di rifr girazione
refrigerazione all'interno della casa è
di fatto un sistema di aria condizionata
molto molto frugale l' inventata
un'impresa sociale non per caso gramin
non per caso quella a cui è
il il premio Nobel Mohammad
junus
Allora quando io parlo coi miei amici e
colleghi energetici ovviamente diciamo
sono divertiti da questa soluzione
perché perché loro stanno
lavorando per la grande industria dei
condizionatori in grandissimi progetti
di ricerca che riguardano l'aria
condizionata e naturalmente stanno su
una traiettoria tecnologica loro e
l'industria dei condizionatori una
traiettoria tecnologica molto energivora
che ha bisogno di tantissime energie e
quindi in Indonesia si usano tanti
condizionatori in maniera
energivora naturalmente usando tanta
energia si comincia a emettere tanta CO2
tanta CO2 fa aumentare la temperatura e
questo al primo giro è un'ottima notizia
per i
nostri venditori di condizionatori e per
i nostri ricercatori che stanno su su
quella traiettoria perché Più è caldo e
più si vendono condizionatori e più si
vendono condizionatori più si usa
energia più c C'è CO2 più aumenta la
temperatura più si vendono
condizionatori finché a un certo punto
il giro finisce Perché Perché non ci
possiamo più permettere di usare così
tanta energia perché le conseguenze
climatiche di questo sono di fatto un
ostacolo Insuperabile per continuare a
usare quel tipo di tecnologia E allora
che cosa dobbiamo fare piantare bottig
di plastica nei nostri muri ovviamente
no però forse una visitina a quei due
signori che si sono inventati questo
metodo possiamo farla non per copiare la
soluzione perché noi abbiamo la
tecnologia E dobbiamo orgogliosamente
difenderla ma per imparare qual è il
loro assetto mentale Qual è la loro
interpretazione di innovazione in un
mondo di risorse scarse e vincoli
abbondanti Oppure potremmo farci un
giretto nel
deserto e nel deserto guardare le tane
delle termite le tane delle termiti nel
deserto ovviamente devono sono dei delle
case che devono resistere in condizioni
di estremo caldo di giorno e di estremo
freddo di notte e le termiti se le sono
inventate con un'architettura interna
tale per cui la temperatura sta sempre
costante all'interno della casa anche la
natura ci ha offerto una soluzione
frugale brillantissima Allora forse ci
sono tre posti da cui possiamo imparare
la natura l'emisfero
del mondo è il terzo settore perché sono
tutti posti in cui c'è abitudine a usare
poche risorse e a superare vincoli molto
molto grandi per cosa
chiuderei citando un grande economista
Dick Nelson che Nel 1974 ha detto questa
cosa 1974 5 anni dopo l'atterraggio
dell'uomo sulla Luna dice vabbè Nel 1974
adesso abbiamo portato un uomo sulla
luna cioè abbiamo risolto un problema
tecnologico difficilissimo Com'è che non
siamo ancora riusciti a risolvere il
problema del Ghetto e adesso ci portiamo
50 anni dopo cioè
oggi abbiamo fatto passi avanti
straordinari nella tecnologia stiamo
guardando a Marte invece che la luna Ma
il problema del Ghetto è sempre lì
[Musica]
Grazie